and you always come in to Little Neck  right I recognized your headphones in  here very pretty  I'm in the middle of the park do not  like compliments I'm Elliot hey  something called Ewing's sarcoma did you  find out yesterday why am I the first  person that you tell this to us we're  strangers  let me just relevant to the situation  everybody else with a freaked out I'm  pretty freaked out  [Music]  well there's a dude here like B dude  there's a dude are you still gonna be  attracted to me haircut  why are you so nice to me I'm ruining  your life before this gets worse I'm not  going anywhere  what get married now that's bridge  [Music]  let's go to the strip club that's not  how marriage works make sure you know  how marriage works  I just want us to be on the same to him  [Music]  you  you